guys my name is welcome back to my Ray
tracing series now last episode was an
absolute Banger if you haven't seen it
check it out up there we talked about
path tracing for the first time and we
started rendering some images that
accumulate into something a little bit
more realistic looking now at this stage
there are so many things we could talk
about but I thought it would be helpful
to take a little bit more of a look at
the code that we've actually got at the
moment and see how we could optimize it
and make it run faster there are
honestly so many ways we could optimize
our current code base because I haven't
really been writing it with performance
in mind we've just been trying to get
all the actual physical code down on
paper so to speak whilst also trying to
keep it as simple as possible so that
it's just easier to understand for the
majority of people and just before
recording this episode I actually ran a
profile in this code just to see where
we're at and there's a lot of room here
for optimization which is great because
the worst thing in software development
always is when you have no room for
improvement like that is a very bad
place to be so as a little task for all
of you guys my Christmas present to you
a little holiday task if you will take a
look at this current code base and see
what you can optimize run some profiles
over it see what is running slowly and
figure out if there is an alternative
way to achieve effectively the same
result I'll be creating an issue on
GitHub where you guys can discuss this
but today we're going to be keeping it
more or less simple and we're going to
take a look at something called
multi-threading what is multi-threading
well put simply multi-threading allows
us to take advantage of our currently
running Hardware to perform tasks in
parallel what that means is that instead
of us kind of running through each line
of code that we have here sequentially
meaning we execute one line after the
other and then we go back to like all of
our pixels that we're trying to render
and we progress to the next pixel and we
go over it instead of doing that kind of
one at a time we can actually do
multiple pixels at once at the exact
same point like in physical time and the
reason that that's possible and why it
works is because our CPUs have more than
one core typically CPUs these days have
like at least four cores maybe eight
cores that's what my laptop here has 16
cores 32 cores 64 cores the more cores
you have the more things you can do at
once at the same time and really the key
here is that if we actually take a look
at our code and what it's doing we have
to Loop through quite a lot of pixels in
a full HD image so 1920x1080 if you
multiply those two numbers together you
get a number that's around 2 million
what that means is we have 2 million
individual pixels that need shading and
by shading I mean we need to determine
what color should be at that pixel so
what that means is that as we go through
here and we go through like 1 million or
2 million pixels total the key is that
none of these pixels are related to each
other what I mean by that is if we draw
like a grid of pixels so these are all
kind of individual neighboring pixels of
our image image in order for us to
calculate the color for this pixel we
don't need to know the color of this
pixel or this pixel right if we are
actively trying to work out any one of
these given pixels we don't need to for
example wait to find out the final
resulting color of this guy here we can
just do this completely independently
and since it is an independent operation
there is no reason for us to kind of do
one after the other we can do it
effectively in any random order we want
and definitely at the same time and as I
mentioned if our CPU has like 8 cores
and 16
logical processes because each core is
kind of divided into two like Hardware
threads but that's a topic for another
video let's just focus on the cause here
if we have eight cores what that means
is that we could basically do like eight
pixels at once
more or less now that sounds pretty good
doesn't it like we look eight times
right we can just eight times more work
we can do immediately if we had a way to
just split this up into different chords
isn't that exciting well yes I mean
eight cause eight cause is not bad right
but like
what about 8 000 cars wouldn't that be
better the answer is yes yes that would
be better and that's why gpus have
thousands of cores and RTX 3080 for
example has eight and a half thousand
cores so it kind of makes our eight core
CPU look like a bit of a joke and that's
also why graphics cards are so much
better at Graphics because aside from
having their actual kind of physical
traits specifically optimized for the
kind of math that we need to do for like
graphics and rendering they also just
have an insane amount of cause and the
reason for that is because of what I've
just described pixels are more or less
independent from each other completely
so we just need to physically Brute
Force get through two million pixels and
since they're all kind of calculated
independently we can theoretically just
do them all at once because we never
have to wait for the result of a
previous operation to determine our
current pixel's color and of course what
I'm referring to here is like throughout
one pass specifically of course if our
renderer has many passes then there
might be some kind of dependency on a
previous past to do a future pass but
I'm talking about all the pixels like
within one pass okay anyway we're
getting a little bit complicated here
the plan for today is let's just dive in
and make this multi-threaded like
there's no reason for this to run on a
single core Because the actual math and
like all of these operations that happen
here which calls into per pixel and that
will like call Trace Ray and do all of
the actual Ray tracing there's no reason
for this to be done on a single chord so
let's change that but first I want to
talk about the sponsor of this series
brilliant brilliant is a really really
good fit for this series because what it
is is an amazing website filled with
lots and lots of really high quality
courses on various stamp topics how does
it tie into Ray tracing well they have
like all of the math that you need to
know for Ray tracing on their platform
all the way from a gentle introduction
to math via their Everyday Math course
to something a bit more serious such as
linear algebra which is really really
important for all the stuff we're doing
here not sure what normalizing is not
sure what the dot product is they have
courses on those exact topics and the
thing that sets them apart is just how
well made the courses are how
interactive they are how engaging they
are they have these widgets you can play
with they present all this stuff to you
visually and Visually in my opinion is
by far the best way to learn when you
connect that with the fact that they'll
quiz you after all of their lessons to
make sure that you actually understand
what you're learning and answer the
questions correctly it just makes for a
really good effective learning
experience and the best thing about
brilliant is that you can get started
for free just go to brilliant.org the
Cherno the link will be in the
description below check out their
courses go through some of them see what
they have to offer and if you do fall in
love with it then brilliant have been
nice enough to offer the first 200 of my
subscribers 20 off an annual membership
the holiday season is a great time to
brush up on your mouth and Brilliant is
the best place to do that huge thank you
brilliant as always for sponsoring this
video okay so how do we do this how do
we multi-thread this code as quick
quickly as possible in as simple of a
way as possible now you know me I love
my disclaimers because computer science
is just such a complicated thing that I
feel like if I don't explain what could
have been people will not be happy there
are many ways to multi-thread this card
you could design any level of
abstraction over it you could split it
up into as many threads as you want
really you could for example group like
pixels into clusters into like tiles do
it that way you could do it like by scan
line like horizontally for example what
I'm gonna do here is I'm actually going
to show you something really simple that
exists in C plus plus 17 and above and
what that is is a function called scd4h
so what this basically is is a 4-H Loop
so instead of us riding a for Loop and
the four being like an actual keyword in
the language this is kind of a function
that kind of takes in our starting
iterator our kind of ending iterator and
then a function like a Lambda for us to
actually run each iteration now the
special thing about std4h though is that
we can specify something called an
execution policy which means how do we
want this to execute and you probably
guessed it there's an execution policy
called parallel and what that will do is
it will just create like a parallel for
Loop but to set this up it's a little
bit finicky because what we actually
need here if we take a look at the
arguments we need like begin iterator
and an end iterator and we don't really
have that we just have integers so what
we need to do is actually create some
kind of data structure around this that
will contain an iterator going from zero
to width and from zero to height so what
I want to do is over here I'm just going
to create a vector that's probably the
simplest way to do that we're going to
make it a vector of U and 32ts because
that is the type here and we're just
going to call this horizontal maybe I'll
call it image horizontal iterator or
something and we'll also create
um an image vertical iterator and so
these two guys I'm not going to
initialize them until we actually go
into our resize function because that's
where we create our actual image so over
here down the bottom I'm just going to
add a little resize to this to be this
is the horizontal one so it's going to
be the size of width so that's how many
pixels it will contain the vertical one
will be the same but for height and then
I just need to fill them with the values
zero through with -1 and 0 through
height minus 1 respectively and the way
that I'm going to do that is just really
simple I'm just going to write a for
Loop to do this you could probably use
like some kind of fancy C plus 17 or or
maybe below that I don't know some kind
of function to just do that in one line
this is like two lines and if you've
seen my like making it faster video you
know that I don't really like to use the
fancy functions I just like to do things
the simple way because that way you can
see exactly what's going on and you
won't wind up in a situation where it
just takes longer for no reason so let's
go through uh basically from zero to
like width minus one is what I will be
and then we can just set that into our
horizontal iterator so that will just be
horizontal iterator I equals I we can
just address it like that because we've
resized it obviously so that will exist
then we'll just duplicate these lines
here and do the same thing for Heights
we'll go through the vertical iterator
here and just go from zero to height
minus one so now what we have is like
because this is wrapped inside a vector
we actually have like an iterator that
comes with that vector and so we don't
really have to do anything too special
aside from the fact that like if we look
at this for Loop and how we can rewrite
it to fit this 4H then you can see it
goes from zero which of course will be
like the first kind of index of this
vertical iterator all the way to height
minus one so we can just take our
vertical iterator because you can see
that's our outer for Loop
so image a vertical iterator dot begin
image vertical iterator Dot and and then
we need to specify a function so this
will be some kind of Lambda and we can
specify
uint32ty as of course our like iterator
value I guess at that position so over
here we have a nested for Loop so what
that means is that the contents of this
for each function will be another scd4h
and I just want to point out just in
case this is confusing to anyone what
we've done is we've effectively just
Rewritten this so the code that goes
inside this body here is the body of the
for Loop so whatever we had inside the
for Loop that kind of goes in here right
that's all it is it's just kind of
providing a Lambda of a function to be
executed for each iteration so here you
could argue that like realistically how
is this going to run because you have to
realize that at the end of the day like
I don't know what our image resolution
is uh because like this whole whole
monitor that I'm using here is actually
1920x1080 so there's no way it's that
big but just for an example let's
consider it is 1920 by 1080. that would
be as I mentioned about 2 million pixels
now if we were to also put another std4h
inside here
does that make sense well if we did that
then again we would potentially be
dispatching 2 million iterations of this
now we do not have 2 million cores for
our CPU to kind of assign all that work
to like nowhere near that we have eight
right so in other words what I'm saying
is that even though this will work fine
if you do that and we can actually play
around with it I'm actually kind of
interested to see if there'll be any
performance difference but you have to
realize at the end of the day that if
you if you try and create more threads
then you have cores on your computer or
hyper threads you have on your in your
actual CPU then you're not really going
to obviously your performance is not
going to improve in fact it could
actually decrease so just be aware of
your actual Hardware now of course
Hardware differs and that's why there is
actually a way for you to easily just
query C plus plus and figure out like
how many cores or how many threads do I
actually have available there's a simple
function you can use called STD thread
and then Hardware concurrency which will
actually tell you how many concurrent
threads you can actually create so
that's really really useful because of
course at runtime based on the the
platform it's running on and the actual
like Hardware configuration will tell
you what you can do but anyway if we did
assume an image size of 1920x1080 then
this for Loop is going to essentially
dispatch 1080 iterations and what that
means is that like again we have that's
a lot more than eight right so that will
saturate the available threads that we
can create and so because of that I'm
not too worried about having to create
another one of these to make sure we
actually spread the workload across all
of our available threads but let's do
that anyway because we did create those
two kind of iterators the horizontal and
the vertical one but then we will
actually compare because like this is a
bit unscripted I actually don't know I
didn't try that before this video so I'm
interested to see what will happen now
when we actually put this inside here
because we're inside a Lambda we need
access to this there's a couple of ways
to ensure that we can just add an
ampersand into this kind of capture
block here or we can add this it's going
to effectively be the same here because
this is obviously part of the class so I
might just add that I don't really like
just arbitrarily adding this or this
because you kind of it doesn't show you
what gets captured and sometimes if
something is being like incorrectly
referenced or maybe copied it can just
be
harder to deal with it can it can
introduce bugs or effect performance so
I kind of like to actually know and the
other thing we'll need is y so and the
reason for that is because you can see
this inner loop here obviously uses y so
we need to pass Y in as well as this
like that so I'll just I'll just write
this code and we copy Y and we copy this
but this is a pointer so we're not
actually copying this class obviously
we're just referencing it kind of okay
so that's the horizontal iterator we
have everything so this this kind of
section here is where this exists and
all we need to do is copy the code and
paste it in that's it no errors no
nothing everything works beautifully so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to do
a little Define Mt for multi-threaded
we'll Define it to one and then I'm just
going to write fmt we'll do it we'll do
kind of this new code of ours else we'll
do this old code so that way we can
easily just compare like the performance
and see how it's running and uh yeah I
mean I think that's it so let's go ahead
and just shut multi-threading off just
so we can get like a little Baseline
we're running in release mode of course
and you can see our rendered times like
around 60 milliseconds 65 sometimes
milliseconds per frame just on the base
camera view because that's important
obviously if we move the camera and we
have more pixels to Shadow a bit slower
so let's go ahead and turn that on and
hopefully my screen recording software
will record fine okay and you can see
that our performance is
exactly the same
so
what happens so what I've done here is
I've just Rewritten this code to be
exactly the same I just switched it
around to using 4H the critical part
here is that you have to
obviously specified the execution policy
to be parallel otherwise you won't be
multi-threading this so what we need to
do is specify an execution policy if we
actually look at this 4-H function we
have two signatures one that is like the
iterators and the function and then the
first one here which also takes in this
Expo which is an execution policy now
that's inside the execution header so we
need to make sure we include execution
and then if we come down here as the
first argument we can specify SCD
execution and then
paw path for parallel and if we plop it
into this guy over here as well and hit
F5 then now instead of about 65
milliseconds you can see we are
magically on 27 milliseconds and it's
basically like the same kind of scenario
but you can just see that obviously like
the way it trades this is much faster
and of course it's going to depend like
the performance is going to depend what
we're looking at because more bounces
will happen here and some more math will
happen here versus like the Miss kind of
function if if that gets inverted since
we didn't hit anything but overall you
can see that's kind of the the
performance now I don't know if my
capturing software is capturing this
well because if we actually take a look
at task manager and we go to the
performance you can see that my CPU
usage is a hundred percent and like if
you just take a look at this what I can
do we just go to details so
raytracing.exe
set Affinity if I just like maybe ban it
from like three cores okay so maybe my
screen recording software is recording
better because I've just banned this
program from running on the first three
cores so we have a little bit for OBS
but you can see that it's saturated
everything
except for those three cores because I
have not allowed this program to run on
those cores so that is kind of the
effect I guess of multi-throwning that
of course if we turn that off so now
it's not multi-threaded and we take a
look at task manager you can see the
huge difference so you'll kind of more
or less see that one of these is fully
saturated it's probably not because it's
actually skipping around the different
cores that's just how CPU scheduling
works so if we actually go back into
details
and we go to Ray tracing and this time I
actually set the Affinity to be
specifically like CPU before for example
then if we go back to the performance
then I think this is cpu4 over here you
can see cpu4 has now suddenly like
jumped up to 100 because now I've kind
of locked the program to be specifically
on this core so this was kind of like
the before before we added
multi-threading it was just one core
fully saturated after multi-threading
especially across all of your cores you
saw that it was like just a hundred
percent on every core versus this where
you can see most of the cores are kind
of idle they're not really doing
anything and then this is clearly the
core that we're running all of this kind
of math on so yeah that's that now one
thing I want to do so we had about 25
milliseconds or so per frame one thing I
want to do here is I kind of want to say
okay you know what let's not do this at
all like let's not do the inner for loop
as parallel so I'll just shut that off
with an F0 instead let's do it normally
and the reason why is because we have
1080 if it was 90 20 by 1080 we have
like a we have like way more of these
kind of outer Loops than we have cores
so maybe we can just kind of basically
like what this will do is instead of
like you know if we had like our screen
instead of each one of these pixels kind
of being assigned a thread what's going
to happen is we'll go through and
actually assign entire rows to separate
threads right so if I draw it kind of
the same that's kind of the difference
each one of these will have one thread
to kind of run on versus this kind of
distribution that's going to be the the
effective difference here so I can just
write that so I'm just interested to see
if there's any performance difference
yeah I mean I wouldn't really expect it
about to be honest it almost seems a bit
slower like we're hitting it almost
about we're hitting the 30s sometimes
whereas before if we go back to this
maybe I'll add like a little else 26 28
30. okay no so we are hitting 30 here
sometimes
it's about the same performance so
there's really no difference and again I
wouldn't really expect that to be just
because like we are fully saturating the
available Hardware cores anyway so what
I might do is I might just keep this
initial first method but otherwise
there's kind of the old
non-multi-threader method and I'll push
this to GitHub if you guys want to do
some kind of experimentation and just
see what works potentially better for
you so there you go over two times
faster and again like there's so many
other things to optimize here it
honestly like the distribution of work
wasn't even like the highest priority
optimization but you can see how easy it
is to just Chuck in like a parallel for
Loop and just make stuff run faster
especially if you actually have the
hardware to do so and personally in my
experience this kind of like parallel
for Loop situation has actually
performed really really well like on
Windows using any hardware I've used so
in many cases like throughout my life
when I've tried to write my own kind of
threading situation versus this kind of
parallel for Loop this has actually come
out faster so that's why I do like this
and I do think it's a good way to do
this but if you guys want to try and
write like some kind of you know
clustered threaded grouping per pixel
kind of you know situation the kind of
groups it into tiles or whatever
absolutely do that let me know how it
goes let me know if you can beat this
method and I'd be happy to make a video
about it and we can kind of upgrade to
that situation but otherwise hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please don't forget to hit the like
button as I mentioned I will make like a
GitHub issue with like all of this
discussion regarding optimization so
that you guys can suggest things and
report your results and findings have a
happy holiday season make sure you check
out brilliant.org the channel and I will
see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
thank you